we need to travel back in time to save
each I'd say we all get weird in seven
days
blocks gonna charge in the past
according to China [ __ ] sounds like a
vacation
[Applause]
I mean eyes you have
you
hey youtubers is charlie hopefully you
guys have been having an awesome break
so far there's some new legends of
tomorrow footage from the first couple
of episodes so let's do a breakdown this
is mostly from the first couple of
episodes it looks like they go back to
the 70s like this one of the first stops
that they make in Valentina Vostok is
supposed to be a big part of this story
I think this is her character right here
I haven't seen like a full-on face shot
of her yet but I love the thought that
it's the canaries idea to go back to the
70s first let's go back and have some
fun and then you get the reaction shot
we're all just like WTF is going on
figure Garber is gonna be so much fun on
this series he's like the guy that's
going to react all the crazy WTF cuz
he's like this logical man of science
and most of the younger members of the
cast are going to be doing crazy stuff
like Jax Jackson the other part of
firestorm I think they made a good call
using him as firestorm for this legends
of tomorrow show I mean I really think
that was part of the transition from the
Ronnie Raymond firestorm because they
knew they were going to do legends of
tomorrow when you look at some of robbie
amell season one firestorm scenes you
kind of get the idea like it's just a
little bit more fun having like the
crazier firestorm character Justin that
it plays a little bit more comical like
a little bit more fun in this big
action-oriented show the producers also
said that there were some problems with
the conception of the character to like
originally in the comics Ronnie Raymond
was kind of like this dumb jock
character so I mean they slowly tried to
change that in the new 52 so Jax Jackson
firestorm just a bit of a course
correction i think is going to be a lot
more fun and there's still like all
these characters will still go on arrow
in the flash but for the most part
they're going to be doing this legends
of tomorrow time traveling stuff being
which they just announced like one of
the other big times that they're going
back to is the 1950s and they cast like
this lesbian love interest for the
canary I mean technically she's bisexual
but you get the idea the new his
character was meant to be like this
Florence Nightingale for the canary like
she's she's slowly recovering from the
effects of the Lazarus Pit so this new
love interest woman is going to nurse
her back to health and gleich help her
react llamate to society with a lot of
making out they did say there would be
some sexytime happening on the Waverider
ship they didn't say exactly I think
there's going to be some sort of like
Adam canary ship going on which is
looking like these other characters like
I just I don't see a lot of potential
for love interest like heat wave way too
crazy like I love him you know these bar
fight scenes 70s bar fight is totally
Dominic Purcell like what if they wrote
that scene thinking about him
specifically like I love the 70s like he
just he fits into the
context so well it is also kind of like
a big canary scene too because she's all
about throwing down I would say of all
the characters like the two most likely
to get in a fight would be the canarian
heatwave just because they're both so
hot-headed albeit not quite as
hot-headed his firestorm but but the
jacks Jackson character actually is a
little bit more level-headed than the
Ronnie Raymond character who by the way
has like the best new costume on the
show look the canary gets a new costume
it's pretty cool I say firestorm
definitely best costume that's weapon
though goes to the six-shooter that rip
hunter is wearing cannot wait for them
to explain that you get this real
anachronistic sense from him where it's
like he's wearing these old-timey
clothes like he's like this Wild West
gunslinger but he's a time traveler so
it's kind of like this Indiana Jones
Doctor Who spin to it so I'm really
excited the weird thing I've noticed in
the trailers though they've been posting
is that there isn't a whole lot of
hawkman hawkgirl on the Waverider like
they're in all these group scene so very
clearly I mean I was gonna be traveling
around with each other but whenever
they're moving around the ship like I
haven't seen a whole lot of hawkman
hawkgirl scenes it's usually the other
characters and they actually just
revealed that when they were like coming
up with the idea for legends of tomorrow
for big team up show originally it
started as a Hawkgirl show they didn't
even know that they wanted to use
Hawkman but the biggest reason why they
chose to go with the team like it
started as like this you know normal
show just like you know the flash based
on a single character with a team built
around him it was going to be like the
next step for that like another
character gets their own show builds a
team around them but they felt like
doing a hawkman hawkgirl show would be a
little more Norrish and it feel more
like arrow and they wanted to do
something even bigger and crazier so
that's when it turned into the team up
show so they were like well you know it
had nothing to do with the actors that
we cast like they had already cast
Hawkgirl but they're like we need to
make this even bigger so they started
throwing in the other characters and it
just ballooned into this big time travel
legends of tomorrow team-up show in the
main reason why they're not calling it
justice league JSA jla or justice
society anything like that it's just
because there's like a certain level of
expectation when you use the word
justice like batman superman because the
likelihood of them being able to do any
of those characters is so slim they just
they don't want to give like the middle
finger to fans by like doing justice
league show but being like oh we can
never talk about or reference Superman
so you guys I should let me know in the
comments do you feel like they made the
right call calling the show
legends of tomorrow keep keeping in mind
that they probably would have called it
legends but there's already like a TNT
show called legends so they couldn't
really do that or would you have rather
than called it just the society even if
they would have never been able to do
Superman and Batman I know there's a lot
of rumors going around about season two
maybe not happening because they spent
too much money that's all malarkey I
think you know until we hear official
word from the network about season two
plans just don't worry about it in case
you didn't know episode one's going to
drop on the 21st like the flash arrow
and legends of tomorrow are all coming
back during the same week I recommend
that you watch them in that order
obviously the whole big grand arc of
Legends is going to be taking down
Vandal Savage like he's just out of
control can't wait to see how he came
back from that episode of arrow but
there's also going to be a lot of other
crazy like micro DC Comics adventures
during these different time periods so a
lot of the first couple of episodes is
going to be building the characters out
like setting the premise for the show
but then start to keep your eyes peeled
for like little bits from the comics
that they might turn into big season two
things like as they is they create the
mythology of the show it exists inside
the arrow flash universal like there's
already a lot of things that they've
tease like the multiverse but time
travel is like a whole other big thing
because then you can start visiting
teams from other periods like the Legion
of super-heroes I think I talked about
it that my last legends video but of all
the characters i think i think i'm
looking forward to the white canary the
most just because caity lotz is so great
as that character and she's gonna be so
batshit crazy let me let me know in the
comments like which of these characters
are you most excited to see it go crazy
if you didn't hear firestorm will have
new powers on the show in a mean it's
all from the comics so if you've read
firestorm in the comics it's just doing
some of the things that he hasn't done
yet transmutation seems like the next
logical step I know some of you guys are
asking about the new arrow trailer it
confirms a certain character that was
kind of left hanging in the wind in
episode 9 is not dead I feel like we all
knew was going to go down a certain way
but I'll totally do a new video for
tomorrow I do have a doctor who video to
make later today and then there's new
captain america civil war stuff that I'm
going to do on sunday so be sure to
subscribe to get everything in the
reverse flash ring giveaway still going
on too I'll just I'll do they give away
whenever I post my arrow video tomorrow
why use wait for that arrow video to
post you can click here for the flash
trailer i posted yesterday and you can
click here for the Deadpool red band
trailer so crazy so much awesome stuff
happening right now
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight